wir brauchen den impfstoff überall wir
brauchen ihn in den super laufenden
impfzentren wir brauchen ihn aber ganz
bestimmt jetzt im rahmen der astra
situation in den hausarztpraxen denn ich
kenne jetzt beide seiten und ich bin
sehr unsicher ob wir es schaffen die
patienten in den impfzentren in der uns
zur verfügung stehenden zeit denn da
geht es wirklich um schnelligkeit wieder
einzufangen wieder zu beruhigen auch auf
individuelle aspekte einzugehen denn die
fragen werden kommen ganz sicher
und das können wir im einzel 1
gesprächen den praxen natürlich
exzellent außerdem kennen wir unsere
patienten und wenn ich noch mal eins
dazu sagen darf da müssen wir auch nicht
neuen seiten ausfüllen und mit den
patienten durchgehen
das geht schneller in der praxis und die
anamnese die haben wir auch sowieso in
unserer dateien wir kennen die patienten
und diese dinge werden da nicht
passieren
und insofern werden wir alle sehr sehr
sehr dankbar wenn wir wirklich
einsteigen könnten und zwar ohne große
bürokratische hürde denn wir impfen
schon immer das ist unsere kernaufgabe
das ist was hausärzte immer schon
gemacht haben wir die ganze bevölkerung
durch mit grippe saisonale impfungen und
jetzt pneumokokken bank muss das thema
anfang des jahres auch das ist einfach
unser thema sie können dass wenn
ghadhafi leicht verderben wenn
impfstoffe leicht verderblich sind
brauchen die natürlich eine besondere
infrastruktur eine besondere kühlung
sind dafür dann nicht aber dann wirklich
doch diese impfzentren prädestiniert da
bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher also die
ganz starke kühlung die ist ja schon ein
bisschen zurückgenommen wurden
der impfstoff kann ja durchaus auch im
kühlschrank gut überleben also in einem
im kühlschrank für einige tage und
sollte mal in der hausarztpraxis oder
facharztpraxis oder beim betriebsarzt
tatsächlich noch ein weile geöffnet
worden sein gegen ende der sprechstunde
und dann sind noch vier spritzen übrig
also ganz sicher die für impfen wir da
haben wir wirklich in jedem finger viele
patienten die wir dann direkt anrufen
können und die direkt um uns herum
wohnen das wird kein problem will man
herr montgomery jetzt eigentlich nur
noch verstehen wer oder was hindert die
einbindung der hausärzte warum ist das
immer noch ein problem ist dass alle
abrechnungen und um nein das ist fox
waren als 1800 menschen in diesem
zentrum das kostet richtig geld ja das
kostet richtig richtig viel geld und das
ist eine super gute investition weil das
was sie an der wirtschaft waren dadurch
dass wir gute impfen das ist gewaltig
man nicht vergessen je mehr wir impfen
dass du weniger lockdown je weniger
desto mehr lockt hat nein im moment
heißt das einfach noch daran wir haben
weniger als ein viertel des impfstoffs
kommt von astrazeneca die anderen sind
immer noch mit dem logistik
problembehaftet und wir müssen den
zweigen hinkriegen zu das ist dann für
beck das ist dann johnson & johnson und
das ist astrazeneca als haupt impfstoffe
die kann man ganz normal sagt in der
fläche für ihn ganz normal lagern
das ist die zukunft so und dann ist
natürlich jetzt die letzte frage an
bürger in fulda hamburg was sie
eigentlich denken wann das sein könnte
wann endet in ihrer praxis geimpft und
was ich kann das nicht sagen
die frage stelle ich vielen überall
ich kann ihnen das nicht sagen man hört
auch immer in der presse
es ist im märz in ist es anfang april
jetzt ist es mitte april wir können
ihnen das nicht sagen wir sind alle
bereit
wir können das wir hoffen sehr dass die
bürokratischen hürden nicht hoch sein
werden und dass man wirklich einfach
übergeht zur normalität und impfen in
hausarztpraxen ist normalität wie teuer
wird eine impfung bei ihnen dann in der
praxis seien im vergleich jetzt zum im
zentrum ist auch noch nicht ganz sicher
ich höre irgendwas von 20 euro und kann
sein ich glaube dass im moment sind
sieben euro 51 oder sind also definitiv
wir sind billiger als es woanders
möglich ist ganz bestimmt das ganz
bestimmt weil das las ich in zentren
liegen dann ungefähr bei 100 120 euro
pro impfung also da muss es tatsächlich
auch ein geschäftliches interesse
dahinter geben halten wir das wenigstens
mal fest ganz lieben dank sehr
herzlichen dank nach hamburg für ihre
expertise frau pohl und natürlich weiter
viel glück und irgendwann dann auch
genug impfstoff in der hand das würde ja
genau und schönen gesund bleiben wir
marschieren hier gedanklich in unserer
diskussion noch mal zu dem was wir
morgen auf dem zettel haben neben den
impfungen nämlich wie geht es eigentlich
jetzt mit den instanzen weiter wir sehen
herr müller dass wir auch in berlin nach
der 100 kommen wir haben also nicht nur
dieses problem sondern die zahlen
steigen auch weiter michael kretschmer
sagt er hätte sich eigentlich gewünscht
das ist diese lockerungen gar nicht
gegeben hätte würden sie auch sagen das
war ein fehler dass wir vor zwei wochen
diese lockerungen beschlossen haben und
diesen lustigen masterplan
naja es war ja sehr vorsichtig und
schrittweise und niemand musste das auch
ein zu eins umsetzen wir haben in berlin
auch weniger gemacht als der beschluss
eigentlich her gegeben hat und jetzt ist
hier sehr sodass wir am kommenden montag
darüber sprechen ob wir weiter gehen
wollen und so ist es ja auch formuliert
in dem wie sie sagen lustige plan
da steht drin frühestens ab dem 22
kammern wieder dieses und je nach posen
und ich glaub ich glaube dass wir nicht
in der lage
wo wir weiter gehen können es wäre schon
eine krisen kraftanstrengung mit testen
und impfen das zu halten was wir jetzt
haben aber die nächsten schritte sehe
ich nicht so fern wie eben nicht andere
und test kapazitäten bekommen mit dem
impfen ich muss ein bisschen doch noch
mal nach hamburg gehen
wir haben ja in den praxen schon
angefangen einige bundesländer haben
dass wir haben in 30 praxen angefangen
wollten diese woche ist erweitern auf
100 praxen dort schon zu impfen das gab
dann den rückschlag durch die astra
entscheidung also es heißt wir können
damit starten und wenn wir uns darauf
auf bundesebene auch verständigen können
dann glaube ich kann das sehr schnell
gehen und kann am montag auch ein
begleitender beschluss seien zudem ein
treffen mit der kanzlerin um zu sagen
wir gehen unbedingt in die
hausarztpraxis herr palmer vor den
beiden landtagswahlen wurden die
öffnungen beschlossen
und nach den beiden landtagswahlen
werden sie nun höchstwahrscheinlich
zurückgenommen
ein schelm wer böses dabei denkt ja da
muss ich tatsächlich sagen das ist ein
schelm der denkt böses gerade wenn sie
an winfried kretschmann denken den
ministerpräsidenten von baden
württemberg dann wissen sie dass er sich
immer sehr vorsichtig aus gesprochen hat
und dass er jetzt da vor der wahl
lockerungen versprochen hätte die er
selber dann nachher kassieren will das
ist wirklich eine unterstellung die ich
für völlig abwegig halten
er ist er bei seiner linie immer
geblieben und die infektionszahlen haben
sich halt leider anders entwickelt als
erhofft wir waren in baden württemberg
schon bei 46 und jetzt gehen wir auch
kurz vor die 90 die haben doch gerade
für berlin zitierte frau pipette die
regierung bei dem letzten treffen diese
lockerungen beschließen sollen oder war
das eigentlich ein fehler weil man weder
die tests noch die impfungen zur
verfügung hatte um lockerungen zu
begleiten das aufzugreifen die zahlen
haben sich anders entwickelt als erhofft
aber eigentlich nicht anders als
erwartet zumindestens wenn man auch sage
ich mal die epidemiologen gehört hat
hätte oder die zuhört dann hat das immer
wurde immer gesagt die neuen virus
varianten haben
höheres ausbreitung potenzial und es
wird dazu kommen dass wir mehr
infektionen sehen und deshalb ist es nur
möglich zu an einer stelle zu lockern
wenn wir an anderer stelle das
kompensieren und wenn das nicht möglich
ist durch rasches impfen oder durch
ausreichend kapazitäten dann geht es
schlicht und ergreifend nicht und das
ist das was wir jetzt wieder gesehen
haben und ich hoffe dass man es jetzt
verstanden hat dass es nichts bringt ist
immer wieder zu probieren und wir werden
im lichte dieser inzidenz zahlen aber
auch wieder nicht wissen ob es jetzt die
tanten waren oder der baumarkt oder die
schulen oder der friseur
wir werden wieder nicht wissen was
eigentlich zu dieser steigenden inzidenz
geführt hat oder wissen sie das also im
detail für den einzelnen fall kann man
das natürlich nie sagen aber es ist eine
summe dieser effekte zusammen mit
sicherheit es ist die neue virusvariante
aber es ist natürlich auch der
wiedereinstieg in grundschulen in kitas
aber auch eben die anderen öffnungen die
sie angesprochen haben das alles
zusammen auch private kontakte man
sendet natürlich auch immer ein signal
wenn man sagt wir können dies und jenes
öffnen und machten hier und da eine
ausnahme für den friseur beispielsweise
das animiert denke ich auch schon bürger
zu sagen okay wenn das möglich ist dann
gehe ich mir auch meine kleine ausnahme
am rande und sehe das etwas lockerer
weil es geht ja in die richtige richtung
und das ist glaube ich auch immer ein
bisschen fatales zeichen also sie sagen
dann kommt die mangelnde disziplin noch
viel mehr dazu weil man den menschen
suggeriert das ist das weiß ich zum teil
erleben
ein bisschen sicherlich nicht bei jedem
so aber ich erlebe das auch schon so
mancher herr montgomery eine neue frisur
und zwei blumentöpfe weiter sind wir in
der situation die wir eigentlich
vermeiden wollten wir sind in einem lock
down jojo ja wir sind uns zu wir sind
nicht sehr lernfähig es hat drei länder
gegeben die haben extrem locker gemacht
israel frankreich und irland waren sehr
erfolgreich und genau den fehler danach
gemacht den wir jetzt auch machen sie
haben zu früh wieder aufgemacht weil das
ist so weil der druck der bevölkerung
aber auch die begonnenen chancen für
kinder in schulen in kitas das sind
alles dinge die man berücksichtigen muss
und dieses virus verhält sich ja total
unverhältnismäßig in dem es uns zeit
leisten gibt mit denen wir so schlecht
umgehen können ist es schwer den leuten
bei einer niedrigen incidents zu sagen
wir müssen das jetzt noch zwei wochen 3
durchhalten wenn man die inzidenz 35 ist
sieht dann aber auf 100 zu schieben also
dass plötzlich die 35 waren ja das neue
50 und dann plötzlich war 135 da kommt
keiner mehr mit hätten wir und das trage
ich hätte hätte fahrradkette dabei
hätten wir damals diesen lockt dann noch
länger durchgehalten stünden wir heute
besser da aber wir sind nicht davor
gefeit so lange wenig alle geimpft sind
und solange es keine therapie gibt hilft
als einziges die maske der abstand die
hygiene
das ist das einzige was uns hilft
infektionen zu vermeiden und mutationen
zu finden so wir müssen uns aber
trotzdem noch einmal diese notbremse
angucken das war ja ein
hochinteressanter vorgang
wir sind eigentlich immer noch im
bahnhof aber ziehen diese notbremse
jetzt wahrscheinlich schon weil wir über
die 110 überm rauschen und das finden in
der tat nicht alle ministerpräsidenten
toll
es ist so eine glückssache mit dem
öffnen und schließen in deutschland
vermeintlich klare absprachen hunderter
notbremse zurück in den lotter
eigentlich war man sich einig also
falsch wäre wenn jetzt versucht er die
notbremse auszuhebeln
es ist kein automatismus man muss genau
sehen woran liegt es in diesem fall dass
die instanzen aus dem ruder gehen und
diese kreise sind aufgefordert das
apathisch umzusetzen wer jetzt an der
notbremse arbeitet um die zu entgehen
er machte in schweren fällen die
notbremse bei 100 verwandeln die
brandenburger gar mit einem raffinierten
dreh in einem brems korridor bis 200 in
landkreise die 100er grenze
überschritten haben sie erstmal
maßnahmen ergreifen sollen das ist eine
klare regelung bei uns also die
kommunale ebene auch selber nach
verantwortung ist beispiel landkreis
elbe elster
seit tagen liegt die inzidenz über 150
trotzdem darf man einkaufen und sich zu
mehreren treffen
die schulen haben auch auf das ende der
bremsspur ist hier nicht zu erkennen ich
möchte sinnvolle maßnahmen umsetzen
landkreis elbe-elster die auch wirkung
zeigen die offen akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung zeigen die ich erklären kann
klingt irgendwie gut macht aber aus der
notbremse wieder so eine zahl die sich
abnutzt
bevor sie überhaupt zum einsatz kommt
herr müller man hat das gefühl ihre
brandenburger kollegen jonglieren
irgendwie mit der 100 wer muss sich
daran halten wir muss ich nicht dran
halten finden sie das in ordnung
na ja es hat ja auswirkungen für berlin
war es in brandenburg passiert und
umgekehrt und der ministerpräsident hat
jetzt eingegriffen und die
landesregierung beschäftigt sich dann
auch früher mit dem ganzen thema aber
auch hier möchte ich sagen ist es bei
einer ähnlich wie beim impfen man darf
nicht immer nur auf die einen wenigen
maßnahmen gucken über die wir alle immer
reden schule einzelhandel oder theater
oder sport sondern wir müssen dann auch
noch mal breiter gucken was geht und
eine testpflicht zum beispiel durch die
arbeitgeber für die beschäftigten kann
ein thema sein
warum eigentlich nicht wir reden über
testen an schulen bei lehrern und
schülern warum eigentlich nicht auch bei
den arbeitnehmern durch die arbeitgeber
umgesetzt unsere technische universität
hat das untersucht mit unserer home
office empfehlung für die arbeitgeber
hat es im einstelligen prozentbereich
home office umsetzungen dann gegeben
praktisch gar nicht also ich muss nicht
sofort an schule denken ich muss nicht
sofort an die sensiblen bereiche des
privaten lebens denken wenn ich auf der
anderen seite noch möglichkeiten habe
und das ist mir auch wichtig dass das
mitdiskutiert interessanter punkt sie
haben also aufforderung nicht nur appell
sondern echte aufforderung an die
arbeitgeber ihre mitarbeiter zu ihm
nicht zu impfen sondern zu testen ist
damit sie über acht stunden im betrieb
sein können und natürlich ist auf der
anderen seite auch das angebot zu
überlegen dass die belegschaft gleich
gewinnen denn wir machen aus einem roten
rathaus eine textstelle und die
kolleginnen und kollegen dem es an warum
soll das nicht auch in einem unternehmen
möglichst so und dann sind wir bei dem
modellprojekt dass es in tübingen gibt
herr palmer wir haben seit dienstag von
ihnen verfolgen dürfen wie sich die
stadt wieder ein bisschen mehr füllt es
gibt eine test strategie
unter ihrer ägide sie haben die
genehmigung dafür bekommen menschen
einen können wir auch noch mal zeigen
einen tages ausweis auszuhändigen mit
dem sie sich frei testen können um in
die stadt zu kommen in die restaurants
zu gehen natürlich einzukaufen mit
dieser tageskarte kann man sich dann in
der stadt bewegen
wann wissen sie ob das ein guter test
war
wann haben sie erfolg gehabt mit dem
test also frühestens nach etwa zehn
tagen sollen dauert bis man bei sieht er
den infektionen und da wir erst vor drei
tagen begonnen haben kann ihnen dazu
jetzt nichts sagen aber das kriterium
kann ich ihnen
wir wollen herausfinden ob es möglich
ist mehr freiheit mehr stadtleben mit
mehr sicherheit in der pandemie zu
verbinden
denn es gibt zwei gegenläufige effekte
der eine ist was sie gesehen haben dass
in tübingen jetzt auch die
außengastronomie auf gemacht hat und das
theater das er so menschen ihr leben
haben und da erhöht sich das
infektionsrisiko
auf der anderen seite aber verbinden
wird es immer mit dem verpflichtenden
test bevor man in die kultur oder zum
einkaufen gehen das heißt wir finden
infizierte und können die in quarantäne
schicken das wird unsere incident sinken
die zahl der fälle sinken das haben wir
nämlich im winter so gemacht im übrigen
haben gesehen wir kommen damit schneller
runter mit der zahl der infektionen und
spannend ist jetzt die frage was ist der
stärkere effekt ist das herausfischen
der infizierten stärker kommen wir also
besser durch oder ist es zusätzliche
treff angebot stärker und wir haben dann
höhere zahlen als der landesdurchschnitt
und genau deswegen hat das land baden
württemberg diesen modellversuch
genehmigt da bin ich uns kommt
ministerpräsidenten sehr dankbar weil
ich denke dass wir alle miteinander doch
ziemlich klar sehen diese dritte welle
wird sehr stark werden und wenn wir dann
nur noch den lock down als einzige
lösung zur verfügung haben dann sind die
schäden an der gesellschaft eben nach 1
jahr erschöpfen da immer wieder doch
sehr fordernder zeit im locker und so
gravierend dass wir dringend alternative
strategien testen müssen und das tun wir
jetzt sind wir wollen herausfinden mit
dem schnelltest besser durch die
pandemie kommt mit etwas mehr stadt
leben als wenn wir wieder alle locker
machen
hab einmal zwei fragen wer zahlt das das
land baden württemberg oder sie das tat
zunächst sogar mal entspannen denn er
hat ja versprochen zeit achten märz die
sogenannte bürger testung dass alle
einen anspruch für mindestens einen test
in der woche haben da werden unsere
teststationen finanziert und das land
baden württemberg übernimmt die kosten
für alle tests die nicht auf diese weise
übernommen werden aber ich habe auch
noch einen unternehmer andere hand denn
das hätte jetzt lange gedauert bis die
tests gewesen wäre nach der genehmigung
ist versuchst er unter der unternehmer
der eigentlichen start metall werkzeuge
für die autoindustrie macht paul hoorn
kleiner werbeblock hat auf meinen anruf
gesagt er stellt anderthalb millionen
euro zwischen finanzierung bereit und
hat jetzt eine halle mit 350.000 tests
in tübingen gefüllt damit wir sofort
zugreifen können die überall einsetzen
auch für betriebsleistungen für
schulleistungen wir wollen im prinzip
ganz thüringen so engmaschig durchtesten
dass das virus keine neuen opfer mehr
findet so und das wird wenigstens drei
wochen gehen drei wochen wird es auch
begleitet von der uni tübingen und wir
haben auf der anderen seite herr
montgomery natürlich das warnen des rk
es im ohr das sagt ostern sind die
krankenhäuser voll ist dieses testen ist
sind solche test strategien ein echter
helfer um eine brücke zu absolut
absoluten häuser sondern ins leben
zurück ja absolut sinnvoll wie übrigens
auch der von europäischen union
entwickelte impfpass mit dem sie
nachweisen können wir wissen ja zwischen
dass bei beiden impfstoffen 91 prozent
der patient wirklich steril immun sind
also nicht mehr anstecken können also
ist es noch beides zusammen machen den
impfpass damit kriegen wir auch
wirtschaftliches leben auch kontakte
wieder in gang
aber die test strategie von herrn palma
das hat er ja auch schon vorher bewiesen
bei seiner strategie in altenheim die
ist sensationell gut und ich bin
gespannt was dabei herauskommt
vielleicht komme ich zum ostereier
sammeln mal nach thüringen am wochenende
nämlich ist ja sagen wenn die kleinen
berlin live
ein friedliches angebot sehr schnell und
er selbst tests können natürlich dafür
sorgen dass die infizierten zahlen erst
mal hoch gehen weil wir eben mehr tests
zusammen und weniger dunkelziffern wenn
das weiter gemeldet wird natürlich auf
der anderen seite ermöglichen wir uns
natürlich viel schneller die menschen zu
finden die andere infizieren können weil
das nicht mehr die drei tage bz es
dauert wo schlägt ihr herz sagen sie wir
brauchen jetzt unbedingt mehr von diesen
test streitigen ja wir sollten unbedingt
testen weil es geht müssen alles daran
setzen dass die die infiziert sind sind
die auch erkennen und damit die bürger
senken und jede infektionskette so früh
möglich dann auch abbrechen können das
ist ja der sinn des ganzen
deshalb müssen wir ganz ganz häufig
testen gerade weil diese tests ja ein
bisserl weniger gut die infektion
erkennen als eine pcr-test das kann und
das können wir ausgleich indem wir sehr
sehr häufig ganz viele testen manche
herr müller ich habe es am anfang der
sendung gesagt buchen parallel dazu
jetzt schon die reise nach mallorca malu
dreyer sagt heute ihr wäre lieber die
leute würden eben wie im feld weit
wandern und nicht fliegen und dann das
virus nach deutschland ein schleppen
muss man sich sowas nicht eigentlich
auch vorher überlegen ja wir haben auch
darüber alle gestaunt und es muss auch
einher gehen mit einem mit einer test
licht für die reiserückkehrer das geht
so nicht dass man in der ganzen welt
herumreisen kann offensichtlich hier in
deutschland wird es immer mehr
eingeschränkt und wenn man zurückkommt
gibt es nicht mal ein test weil
offensichtlich mallorca kann ich bin als
risikogebiet eingestuft ist das geht so
nicht auch das wird ein thema der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sein wenn
noch mal diese hängt diese kombination
von impfen und testen das ist der
erfolgsweg und so wie herr palmer so
machen es einige von uns wir auch in
berlin wir müssen erfahrungen sammeln
mit dem testen wie wird es angenommen
wie funktioniert das vor ort geht das
für 500 leute ins theater wollen
funktionieren die selbsttests nur über
die erfahrung von impfen und testen
kommen wir zurück in die normalität und
das muss auch für die reiserückkehrer
gelb einmal was würden sie sagen tasche
trotzdem packen für mallorca jetzt nicht
die nächste merken blog dahin bestimmt
nicht also erstens tübinger schöner als
und zweitens kann ich das wirklich nicht
nachvollziehen da bin ich ganz bei herrn
müller dass das jetzt möglich sein soll
während die hotels überall in
deutschland nicht öffnen dürfen das
ergibt keinen sinn
herr montgomery und spätestens im sommer
haben wir dann den vollen reiz wenn wir
sehen welches leben in großbritannien
möglich ist in israel möglich ist und in
den usa möglich ist oder haben wir es
bis dahin geschafft
auch bis zum sommer haben wir ja
vielleicht 50 prozent der bevölkerung
durch geimpft
und es gibt ja auch sehr viele menschen
die sich sehr vernünftig verhalten das
ist ja etwas das wir manchmal vergessen
wir reden über die 15 oder 20 prozent
die sich unvernünftig verhalten und
vergessen dabei dass ganz viele menschen
ja auch unter dem lok-trainer dem ein
sehr leiden und die sich brav halten und
dann mit angucken müssen wie die
hedonisten draußen ihnen im grunde
genommen die zahlen kaputt machen und
das leben kaputt machen das wird sich
alles besser wenn wir mehr geimpft haben
und deswegen kann man nur sagen impfen
impfen das ist der schlüssel zur zukunft
und solange wir nicht wünschen können
müssen wir weiter die maske tragen
abstand halten und die gegner der schon
gesagt vor einreisen dürfen wir reisen
was sagt die biologin und epidemiologin
dürfen wir das es ist erlaubt aber wir
sollten uns nichts desto trotz damit
sehr zurückhaltend bewegen also wir
sollten das vermeiden von immer es geht
um uns selbst willen und um uns auch in
zukunft ja auch niedrigere zahlen zu
ermöglichen es die welt haben auf den
montag herr müller haben sie schon
gesagt freuen sie sich besonders
mit da wird es natürlich ein wieder
widerstrebende auch interessen und
wünsche der ministerpräsidenten geben
luca app werden sie vorschlagen
wahrscheinlich dieses arbeitgeber test
pflichten oder die pflicht zum testen
das ist wichtig und welche positionen
kommt von berlin noch das rechte
erstmals schon und bei der low carb sage
ich auch ganz klar ich mache es auch
alleine ich warte da jetzt nicht mehr
wir können nicht immer auf den
langsamsten warten sondern es muss jetzt
vorangehen
gerade wenn wir wie in tübingen oder in
berlin und anderen stellen jetzt dinge
kombinieren wollen uns schneller zu
werden dann ist es richtig dass in einer
mpk zu diskutieren richtig zu sehen dass
man möglichst lange beieinander bleibt
dafür werbe ich immer aber es muss dann
auch eine entscheidungsspielraum geben
und den will ich mir bei der app und
auch bei der priorisierung in den
nächsten schritten und bei dem
einbeziehen der hausärzte den wenig mehr
auch erkennen
in dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
oder es aber alleine machen weil sie
diese tür öffne den berlinern
ich glaube nicht dass ich alleine sein
werde es wird einige ob alle mitmachen
das weiß ich nicht aber es gibt einige
die sagen wir müssen da jetzt mehr dampf
rein kriegen japan noch mal ganz kurz
letzte frage krisen management der
bundesregierung an welcher stelle würden
sie sagen können herr altmaier und herr
sparen und müssen noch die kurve trägt
eindeutig bei der nachverfolgung di luca
ist eine verbesserung aber eigentlich
müsste jedoch die korona waren hab das
alles selbst leisten und dass wir nicht
in der lage sind die
datenschutzbedingungen etwas
zurückzustellen und echtes tracing zu
machen wo doch jedes handy weiß wo wir
uns aufhalten und apple und google das
auch wissen aber die gesundheits eben da
nicht erfahren dürfen wo die infektionen
stattfinden das halte ich für den
größten fehler in dieser pandemie und es
muss dringend korrigiert werden wir
machen hier einen punkt ich darf mich
bei den gästen ganz herzlich bedanken
herzlichen dank nach techniken mit boris
palmer um auch das noch mal zu sagen
unserem letzten geschalteten gast herr
montgomery vielen dank frau pietsch herr
müller sie bleiben bitte auch alles
schön gesund wir hoffentlich jeder der
diese sendung verfolgt bei markus lanz
sitzt jetzt festhalten karl lauterbach
und wir sehen uns kommenden donnerstag
wieder wenn sie mögen 22 und 15 gleiche
stelle gleiche welle bleiben
tschüss
[Musik]